hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
4ch Knights battle royale mode is
probably the most popular video game
currently out there with over 20 million
users around the world at this point
we've all seen a hundred and one videos
about landing spots loot locations and
general tips and tricks so in this video
I wanted to remind you guys of some
mechanics you may not be utilizing fully
here are 21 battle royale skills
you still don't use
let's do this number one as the
population grows and players become more
savvy take a moment to be suspicious of
well everything don't blindly walk into
a house or Hut without listening for
traps or a potential ambush in
particular watch out for these
high-quality weapons seemingly easy to
get your hands on Scout it first as
there may be a bush dweller or a roof
lurker ready to murder your breadcrumb
following us take a second get the upper
hand and end their sneaky bastard ways
speaking of being prepared how many
traps have you picked up and never used
I'm sure you've wasted hundreds of
opportunities to weaken your enemies and
look a few kills too this may seem
overly simple but use your traps if
there's a hut in the middle of nowhere
throw a floor trap in there to wreck
anyone who blindly runs in maybe unleash
a few traps around the towns and cities
you may find if the circle ends around
that location you already have the upper
hand and all because you wasted those
worthless traps number three here's
something a little more specific up in
the northeast of the island is a house
made of building materials we can find
in the game if you're one of those
people who lands on top and starts
smashing through this you are making a
grave mistake as the building we
lovingly call the architect's house is
actually made of the same materials we
find in game it can be edited as such
you can effortlessly change the shape of
anything without using your own
resources
the added negative if you smash it to
pieces with your pickaxe you will not
gather any additional woods
and by the way there's three chests in
the architect's house and if you choose
to run west past the ice-cream van
there's another six to 12 between here
and anarchy acres while we are looking
at editing structures let's showcase
another frustration many of us have have
you ever built a bot with a random group
what am I saying of course you have at
some point though you may need to make a
quick escape and getting out of the back
is your only option and that's when one
of your squad decide to smash a gaping
hole in the structure making a whole
heap of noise
well remind those lovely people that you
all have the power to edit each other's
structures so pop the door in the back
for a quick and quiet getaway in fact
let's press this point a little harder
learn all the editable structure forms
you can the doors don't always have to
be in the center of the wall and the
other structures such as ramps can be
reshaped to offer different types of
defensive options such as a guardrail if
you don't want to take the time to
experiment you'll find hundreds of
videos here on YouTube that showcase
everything you can create number six
when it comes to fighting someone behind
a wall or ramp don't be afraid to shoot
the structures to smithereens if you
have the bullets that cost the one thing
that people miss is that while a wall is
being constructed it requires far less
firepower to knock down so don't
hesitate to shoot the structures
building materials are very weak whilst
they are building so shoot the [ __ ] out
of them if you could spare the bullets I
tend to bring along a gun I have no
intention of using solely to knock down
walls and ramps of other players oh and
in squads you will absolutely melt these
in no time at all from the other point
of view if you're the one trapped behind
the walkers be ready to build repeatedly
to foster opposition to burn through all
their ammunition the longer you survive
should attract other players and they
usually try to take out the loudest
weapon in the fight let's put it bluntly
using every single piece of your
resources is a far better option than
being dead on the ground
number eight out of all four building
options which do you tend to use the
least
I'm guessing into the pyramid right well
now's the time to use them in a
multitude of ways my favorite is during
those flitting moments where you have
two scars and you choose to leave one
behind it's a great idea to hide the
guns underneath the pyramid so other
players don't notice that golden or
purple glow from across the map the
theory here is quite simple we don't
want to give the opposition a better
weapon than they already have
so cover up those goodies like a
makeshift Christmas present there are
other uses for the pyramid to use them
as a hiding place by either dropping
them on top of your squad mates or
editing the corner out pressing confirm
walking back inside the structure and
once again editing the same corner back
in and voila you have a makeshift bunker
also use this to quickly cover fallen
comrades or better still place a pyramid
on top of a downed enemy for a few
reasons actually one it stops them from
crawling away two it stops them feeding
back to their team on your positions and
three it can make revives a little bit
harder especially in a metal pyramid
sadly if the pyramid isn't placed
perfectly it's still possible for your
enemy to glitch through the side or
crawl straight through the structure but
it is hilarious and if you're good at it
you will get abuse like this noob number
10 what do you do during the lobby
section dance run around on the Ninja
Warrior course well a great thing you
probably should be doing is practicing
practice building and most importantly
practice with the weaponry on offer
attempt to land headshots on running
opponents or react to random acts
attacks with short-range weapons
depending on how aggressive you are in
the real match this could be your only
fight practice until the late game
shenanigans especially if you're a
defensive player use those guns you're
unsure about and although you can't see
damage figures you can train your
reactions and generally improve your
game by understanding recoil and bullet
spread number 12 speaking of weapons
remember that the guns are regularly
rebalanced in updates for example
recently the SMG received a buff to make
it a real option on the battlefield so
maybe give that a go
this can work both ways - one week you
may find your weapon has been nerfed and
you have to relearn everything all over
again take the scope they are switch I
personally never click up one day they
will have their day in the Sun so keep
an eye on patch notes to stay up to date
in fact if anybody would be interested
in a quick 90 second video each week
about the patch notes then let me know
your thoughts and I'll definitely
consider it number 12 the silenced SMG
has opened up a great deal of
possibilities for those who are trying
to remain stealthy but what about those
who prefer to be loud and proud I still
suggest taking a silenced SMG with you
just in case the following situation to
pop up firstly those air drops most
people are at this point aware that they
can be shot down but this brings
unwanted attention you are way try
utilizing the silenced SMG to knock down
the balloon as quietly as possible
limiting the chances of being ambushed
another great use for the soundest SMG
is to take down trees blocking your
vantage points in some situations it can
be quite risky to whip out your pickaxe
and knock down a tree and as we've just
mentioned loud weapons bring unwanted
attention your way the silenced SMG is
perfect for clearing sight lines and
remaining relatively unscathed number 40
another tip is to use the storm as soon
as the circle stops moving players stop
checking behind them as they feel safe
try flanking through the storm
obviously you will need the relevant
provisions to heal yourself going
through while coming out the other side
but the tactical edge this gives you can
lead to very easy kills and loot
number fifty with the arrival of the new
city area coming soon here's something
which has the potential to be a mini
game-changer we all know about the
bouncy tires but did you ever stop by a
broken fire hydrant to test those out
just like the tires you can use hydrants
to add a little verticality to your game
there's a few areas where these work
right now allowing players to jump to
roofs without building but at present we
tend to just use them as a park or
pastime
so maybe just maybe these will be
something for the future number 16
probably the biggest underused skill I
would recommend is once again based
around your construction skills let's
set the scene it's the end game you've
created a makeshift base and can hear
your opponent on the outside what do you
do to find them most probably you take
advantage of the high ground and try and
poke your head over the top
well I suggest dropping down in your
base and going into edit mode and
looking through your walls it's not easy
to spot people due to the annoying blue
glow but if you are attentive enough you
are able to get the drop on your
opponent who's fixated on the top of
your erection so sorry if that was not
meant to be a joke move on quickly
number 17 there's a few console-specific
tips to be aware of when playing battle
royale first you can indeed use a mouse
and keyboard if you want to as long as
it's USB compatible you can have a
significant advantage over other players
for me I can't stand playing on mouse
and keyboard as it feels like I'm still
at work but everyone's different you may
Excel and this option will have you
wrecking everyone well until the
dedicated keyboard and mouse lobbies
appear that is alternately check the
controller options for different button
maps especially for aggressive players
who like more combat than building
number 18 we are all getting a little
better at finding those bush wiki's and
staying as vigilant as possible well on
console you have a trick up your sleeves
if you are willing to use it whilst
aiming at a bush slowly track over the
target and if your cursor flickers you
know someone is hiding there this is the
aim-assist designed to help us as
thumbstick aiming is extremely difficult
so take advantage of it and get North
Bush walkies let's quickly finish with a
few points which 99% of people already
know and
actually expect these to be removed in
future updates to minimize fall damage
gold down drops backwards and walk
towards the mountain space there isn't
really a science to this yet as fall
damage seems quite randomized but this
should minimize your fall damage also to
fly further distances when dropping out
of the battle bus just spam your
parachute or umbrella button you can get
to any corner of the map doing this if
you can put up with the annoying sound
and finally number 21 a general tip that
will make you a better player all-round
actively look for confrontations I won't
be judging anyone for using the bush
walkie technique that's how I got my
first win so Who am I to point the
finger well winds breed confidence if I
compare the play I was back then when I
first started to the player I am now
well there's a million miles between one
another confrontation leads to quicker
thinking and faster reflexes over time
your hand will build up muscle memory
and you'll instinctively play the game
instead of reacting yes you'll probably
die many times whilst in practice but 99
people have to die in every singles game
so go for it
play a game like Rambo you never know
you might likely so that was 21
underutilized skills in battle royale
this has been an absolute pleasure
please like and consider subscribing if
this is your type of thing I imagine
from Playstation grenade
you